L'apôtre Paul est ici en train d'évoquer les concepts du fruit de l'esprit, non comme une condition pour que les chrétiens puissent maintenir son salut ou qu'ils puissent conquérir son salut par une vie d'amour.
Ce n'est pas à sa propre force que les croyants auraient la capacité d'aimer et d'émener la vie d'amour qu'on devrait mener par un dévoir créationnel.
On a été créé par Dieu en tant que son image.
Dieu est amour.
On a été créé pour aimer, pour manifester cet amour et pour aimer ce qui est digne d'amour.
Aimer Dieu.
Et manifester l'amour des dieux envers les prochains.
Personne n'arrive à vivre cette vie d'amour.
Et donc ici l'apôtre Paul va présenter les fruits de l'esprit, notamment comme quelque chose qui est les résultats dans la vie de ceux qui ont été l'objet d'un amour qui les a sauvés.
Donc les fruits de l'esprit ici n'est pas la condition pour être sauvés, ni quelque chose qui doit être pratiqué par les forces du croyant.
Mais c'est les fruits de cette œuvre régénératrice de son esprit qui nous a sauvés, qui nous a greffés à Christ.
Et la question de l'apôtre Paul ici, c'est afin de corriger une église qui a été refroidie dans son amour, qui était en dispute.
Il exhorte ces personnes dont il est convaincu d'avoir été véritablement converti, d'avoir été l'objet de l'amour des dieux qui les a sauvés et d'avoir reçu l'esprit qui les unit à Christ.
C'est une exhortation pour qu'ils reviennent à produire ce dont ils ont la capacité de produire, car le Saint-Esprit habite en eux.
Donc ici nous ne sommes pas devant une condition pour les saluts, nous sommes devant une évidence du salut.
La manifestation d'une évidence de ceux qui ont été sauvés par Dieu, de ceux qui ont été aimés par Dieu de manière salvatrice, c'est qu'ils aiment en reproduisant l'amour qu'ils ont reçu de la part de Dieu.
Et donc les fruits de l'esprit, il est quelque part un résultat d'une œuvre d'amour de la part de Dieu, mais il est aussi un résultat qui a été mis à disposition dans la vie du chrétien,
et tous les chrétiens doivent manifester ce type d'amour, doivent manifester ces fruits s'ils veulent être sûrs d'être sauvés.
Et donc la vérité qu'on est en train de considérer la plus large par rapport aux fruits de l'esprit, c'est que les fruits de l'esprit sont nécessaires et suffisants pour identifier un enfant des dieux.
Mais plus que ça, tout enfant des dieux doit identifier chez lui, dans la constance de sa vie après sa conversion, les fruits de l'esprit,
et il doit non seulement identifier d'avoir perçu dans sa vie au moment de sa conversion, ou plutôt dans la constance de sa vie,
mais il doit aussi chercher à maximiser la manifestation du fruit de l'esprit.
Dans cette bataille de nouveau-né, où il y a encore les restes de la chair qui les poussent envers les péchés,
et sa nouvelle volonté prédominante qui va dans la même direction d'aimer Dieu et les prochains,
la force prédominante c'est la nouvelle volonté aidée par les Saint-Esprit.
Et si on peut dire avec tous les soins nécessaires, c'est comme si on dirait que l'obsession du Saint-Esprit déduit en nous,
c'est non seulement qu'on manifeste de manière inconstante plus les fruits de l'esprit que les œuvres de la chair,
c'est que cette présence prédominante du Saint-Esprit en nous fasse que notre vie maximise la production du fruit
qui est plus cohérent avec notre nouvelle nature.
Donc notre nouvelle nature, c'est cette nature qui est née de nouveau par amour, pour aimer,
et donc on doit maximiser la manifestation du fruit de l'esprit.
C'est une œuvre du Saint-Esprit, sponsorisée par le Saint-Esprit, soutenue par le Saint-Esprit,
mais dont la coopération du chrétien joue beaucoup.
Donc afin d'identifier et de maximiser la manifestation du fruit de l'esprit,
les croyants doivent connaître la nature et les fonctionnements du fruit de l'esprit.
C'est un langage qui parle de l'aspect organique d'un arbre,
et c'est très important pour nous de nous rappeler que si les fruits de l'esprit nous sont présentés comme les fruits du Saint-Esprit,
c'est quelque chose qui est avant tout organique,
mais pas quelque chose qui, une branche coupée de cet arbre,
donc la sève et le Saint-Esprit, cet arbre qui est Christ,
une branche de soi-même ne peut pas produire par ses propres efforts ou de manière naturelle,
ses caractéristiques.
Donc par exemple, l'amour, la joie, la paix, je vous rappelle,
on n'est pas en train de parler des vertus qui puissent être naturelles,
que nous puissions trouver chez n'importe qui.
C'est les résultats de l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit,
et c'est donc des vertus qui doivent être considérées par leur perspective pleine ou spirituelle.
Les fruits sont présentés dans les sangliers, et donc il est indivisible.
Je pense que l'illustration de la clémentine,
à laquelle on va évoquer bientôt, va nous rappeler,
c'est plutôt une personnalité, c'est plutôt une intégrité,
c'est plutôt un caractère, et en vérité, c'est la manifestation du Christ en nous.
Voilà pourquoi toutes ces vertus doivent être mutuellement interdépendantes
et manifestées toutes à la une,
ou c'est manifesté selon l'exigence des circonstances,
mais étant toujours équilibrées, liées, symétriques.
Donc c'est un fruit indivisible, c'est un fruit aussi permanent,
car le Saint-Esprit, elle est gage de notre héritage,
et donc nous avons toute l'assurance que si un jour on a été véritablement converti,
le Saint-Esprit sera toujours là, en pourvoyant tout ce qui est nécessaire
pour que nous puissions manifester les fruits de l'Esprit.
Donc on est devant un impératif, manifester les fruits de l'Esprit.
Et il est aussi cultivable, et nous avons considéré
quelles sont les manières principales par lesquelles on cultive la production du fruit,
et notamment ce sont par les moyens des grâces,
l'Église, la communion, la lecture biblique,
individuelle communautaire, les prières,
individuelle communautaire, la participation aux ordonnances,
et de manière très intentionnelle,
nous devons évaluer notre vie en tant que chrétien,
et nous demander par rapport à ces vertus,
quelles sont celles qui sont moins évidentes dans ma vie aujourd'hui,
et chercher à les équilibrer.
Donc une fois qu'on a considéré la nature de l'arbre,
du phénomène, du processus spirituel, organique,
nous passons à considérer,
nous sommes passés à considérer,
les particularités du fruit.
Donc c'est important pour nous de savoir comment ça marche,
mais c'est important aussi de connaître les détails,
de passer de l'arbre au fruit,
et de considérer ces phénomènes qui a la conversion,
la présence du Saint-Esprit en moi,
la nouvelle nature que j'ai reçue,
et qui va aller dans la direction du fruit de l'Esprit,
mais c'est important pour nous d'être très intentionnel
et considérer facette par facette,
vertu par vertu.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire là de considérer
ce qu'il y a l'amour spirituel,
l'amour de l'Esprit,
qui n'est pas l'amour qu'on connaît dans les mondes,
ou la joie, ou la paix, etc.
Et donc nous sommes en train de considérer
la première facette,
l'amour,
et donc pour nous,
la première vérité,
c'est qu'à fond de constater et maximiser
les fruits de l'Esprit chez nous,
nous devons,
de manière très intentionnelle,
constater et maximiser
la manifestation de l'amour dans nos vies.
La semaine dernière,
on a considéré
la première partie,
et la vérité pour nous,
la semaine dernière,
c'était que les croyants
doivent identifier et cultiver
surtout,
l'amour de l'Esprit,
car il est la vertu
capitale
et intégratrice
du fruit de l'Esprit.
Verset 22,
verset 22, pardon,
nous dit
« Mais le fruit de l'Esprit,
c'est l'amour. »
Pour certains commentaristes,
là, on devrait avoir
deux points,
car il est en train
de présenter les fruits
en étant sanglier
et l'amour
comme en étant,
quelque part,
la définition
toute intégratrice,
toute inclusive
de toutes ces autres vertus
qui sont,
quelque part,
les manifestations
variables d'amour.
et donc là,
on ne peut pas arriver
à une assurance totale
et c'est soit ça
la bonne interprétation,
soit la considération
que les fruits de l'Esprit,
c'est,
sanglier,
l'amour,
joie,
paix,
en rappelant
que tout est intégré.
Je pense que
quand on fait
une étude
panoramique
de toutes les Écritures,
nous pouvons être sûrs
et certains
que la vertu capitale
est l'amour
et que toutes
ces autres expressions
sont enracinées
dans l'amour.
Et donc,
l'amour,
elle est la vertu capitale
et tout intégratrice.
1 Corinthiens,
par exemple,
13, 13,
nous dit
maintenant,
donc,
ces trois choses
demeurent,
la foi,
l'espérance
et l'amour,
ce sont les vertus
royales,
capitales,
mais la plus grande
de ces choses,
c'est l'amour.
L'amour est celui
qui apparaît en premier
dans ces passages
et nous avons donc
considéré
dans la semaine dernière
pourquoi l'amour
est la vertu
la plus importante.
On a considéré
donc sa prééminence
dans les passages,
sa prééminence
car c'est lui
qui soutient
toutes les autres vertus,
c'est lui qui donne
quelque part
par l'illustration
de la clémentine.
On a huit vertus ici
plus l'amour.
L'amour,
il pourrait être
la colle,
la fibre,
c'est celui
qui va imprégné,
qui va générer
tous les autres,
c'est les goûts
de l'amour
qui ressort
de ses fruits
et donc c'est
la vertu
toute intégratrice,
c'est l'amour
qui rend authentique
et intègre
toutes les autres vertus.
Donc si je cherche
à manifester
par exemple
les autres vertus
sans l'amour,
on est devant
des contrefaçons
des vertus bibliques.
Donc on a considéré
ça avec tant,
je vous encourage
à revenir.
Et l'amour
est aussi
celui qui est
victorieux souverain
contre les légalismes
et la carnalité.
Donc à la fin des comptes,
si nous cherchons
à être diligents
dans nos disciplines
spirituelles,
fréquenter l'église,
venir là les dimanches,
les vendredis,
et que nous ne sommes
pas motivés
par amour,
on est devant
l'idolâtrie légaliste,
la carnalité
de croire
que notre performance
religieuse
va acheter
l'amour des dieux.
Et si je suis
plutôt motivé
dans mes disciplines
par les menaces
ou les récompenses,
ce n'est pas l'amour,
l'atmosphère
que je respire.
Ce sont des autres
motivations
qui ne devraient pas
être les motivations
moteurs
de la vie
de celui qui est.
donc l'amour
et la vertu
souveraine
à laquelle Paul
va évoquer
pour dire
pour la liberté
vous avez été affranchis
et en même temps
d'être assuré
de cet amour
ne va jamais
permettre
qu'une personne
ne soit pas
diligente
dans ses disciplines
spirituelles,
elle ne va jamais
évoquer
l'effet
d'avoir été
pardonné
pour s'élancer
dans les péchés,
donc l'amour
il est victorieux
suprême
contre les légalismes
mais aussi
contre la carnalité
car c'est impossible
que celui
qui aime véritablement
Dieu
ne veuille pas
lui plaire
par
les disciplines
spirituelles
qui est pour lui
à la fin des comptes
ce n'est pas une manière
de conquérir
l'amour de Dieu
ou ne pas subir
à sa punition
mais pour lui
ce sont des opportunités
pour cultiver
cette relation d'amour
pour approfondir
et donc l'amour
comme dit
l'apôtre Paul
verset 23
la loi n'est pas
contre ces choses
et au chapitre 6
verset 2
il dit
portez fardeau
les uns et les autres
et vous accomplirez
ainsi la loi du Christ
donc celui
qui est converti
il est sous
une nouvelle loi
cette loi
n'est pas la loi
de l'Ancien Testament
mal interprétée
par les pharisiens
avec les poids
des menaces
et des récompenses
cette loi
c'est la loi
du Christ
c'est plus moi
qui vis
Christ vit en moi
et cette vie
que j'ai vis
dans la chair
j'ai vis
par la foi
dans celui
qui m'a aimé
et qui a donné
sa vie pour moi
si nous aimons Christ
et nous avons la conviction
qu'il nous a aimés
c'est impossible
de ne pas
finir pour accomplir
la loi
car Christ est l'accomplissement
suprême de la loi
étant l'amour incarné
et donc
la première chose
pour nous
qu'on a considéré
les dimanche dernier
c'est que les croyants
doivent identifier
et cultiver
surtout l'amour
avant tout l'amour
car
elle est la vertu
capitale
et intégratrice
du fruit de l'esprit
ok
aujourd'hui on va avancer
et considérer
une autre manière
là on va être
plus intéressé
à la définition
biblique d'amour
comment comprendre
l'amour
selon la bible
et donc
la deuxième vérité
c'est que
pour nous en fait
afin d'identifier
de savoir
qu'on peut regarder
nos vies
et identifier
cet amour
et pour que nous
puissions maximiser
les fruits de l'esprit
par l'amour
nous devons
ou les croyants
doivent s'approfondir
dans la connaissance
biblique
soit avec moi
et expérimentale
de l'amour
de l'esprit
donc
biblique
et expérimentale
et j'y rajoute
intentionnellement
expérimentale
car c'est impossible
de connaître
l'amour
biblique
sans qu'il soit
expérimental
et donc
la définition
des termes
c'est les premiers pas
qu'on doit donner
on doit s'approcher
de la bible
et faire ce travail
de chercher
à identifier
quels sont les mots
principaux
ou quels sont
les mots principaux
que la bible
nous présente
quand elle parle
d'amour
donc on a déjà
parcouru
galate
et on a été
face
à deux mots
principaux
qui sont traduits
par amour
ici dans les fruits
d'esprit
on est devant
les mots
agape
mais partout
il y a les mots
caris
qui signifie
parfois grâce
parfois tout simplement
amour
et donc c'est très important
pour nous
de nous approcher
du texte
et être intéressés
dans un premier moment
à la définition
des termes
donc caris
grâce
c'est ce qui fournit
la joie
les plaisirs
les délices
la douceur
les charmes
la tendresse
et même
la grâce
du discours
donc pourquoi
j'insiste
la connaissance
de l'amour
doit être toujours
expérimentale
c'est car même
dans la définition
biblique
du terme
toutes les explications
sont profondément
expérimentales
la grâce
elle nous est présentée
au charisme
ce type d'amour
comme la bonne volonté
des dieux
la bonté des dieux
la faveur des dieux
quelque part
la grâce
pour ce qui concerne
la faveur des dieux
envers nous
une race pécheresse
la relation des dieux
envers nous
une race pécheresse
la grâce
elle est
la mère
de toute faveur
de toute bénédiction
la grâce
elle est la mère
par exemple
de la miséricorde
car la miséricorde
c'est un dieu
qui ressent
des douleurs
dans les cordes
à cause
de notre misère
et qui a déterminé
à nous élever
ou nous enlever
de cette misère
sauf qu'un dieu
sans
trois fois sans
ne peut pas
faire cette faveur
envers nous
sans trahir
par exemple
sa plainte
sans
qui est juste
ce qui est pur
ce qui est sans
et donc
cette grâce
c'est
même lorsqu'on
ne mérite pas
Dieu va manifester
par exemple
sa compassion
sa patience
sa miséricorde
il sera aussi
déterminé
à trouver
un moyen
pour pouvoir
nous enlever
de notre misère
de manière
juste
voilà pourquoi
l'évangile
nous est présenté
comme l'amour
des dieux
manifestés
par grâce
par la grâce
vous êtes sauvés
en quel sens
c'est un amour
qui cherche
à régler
internellement
dans la crise
trinitaire
à la croix
à Christ
n'était en train
de payer
rien à Satan
il était en train
de payer
à Dieu
ce qu'on devrait
souffrir
afin qu'en restant
parfaitement juste
il puisse manifester
son amour
mais cet amour
des dieux
n'était pas
intéressé
tout simplement
à nous sortir
de notre misère
mais il a voulu
nous amener
au lieu
suprême
de sa générosité
en étant déterminé
à nous purifier
nous sanctifier
nous glorifier
et nous faire
asseoir
dans les lieux
célestes
en Christ
donc cette
remontée
du fond
de la fossée
au lieu
le plus élevé
c'est l'expression
de la grâce
de Dieu
ok
et notamment
quand on pense
à la manière
particulière
par laquelle
Dieu
a dû
justifier
sa grâce
envers nous
c'est là
où nous approchons
de la conception
d'amour
la plus élevée
pour tous les chrétiens
car afin
de pouvoir
exercer sa grâce
envers nous
Dieu a dû
manifester
un amour
contre conditionnel
lorsqu'on était
encore ennemi
ennemi
des dieux
fils des colères
fils des perditions
mais
Dieu
à cause
du grand amour
dont on nous a aimé
Jean 3
dit que
Dieu a tant
aimé
les mondes
qu'il a donné
son fils
donc la conception
de l'amour
en tant qu'agapes
c'est une conception
d'amour
qui nous dirige
plus vers la conception
de cet amour
sacrificiel
contre conditionnel
cet amour
qui fait
Dieu
qui veut
exercer sa grâce
et sa faveur
envers nous
cette faveur
imméritée
et qui fait
que Dieu
ne mesure pas
ou qu'il mesure
très bien
plutôt
les coûts
que ça va
représenter
pour lui
de sacrifier
son objet
suprême
d'amour
son fils
afin
de pouvoir
nous rendre
sa faveur
ce qui fait
que pour les chrétiens
même si
dans notre misère
on s'approche
des dieux
très intéressés
aux bénédictions
temporelles
si nous comprenons
quels sont
les enjeux
à propos
de notre salut
et que nous
comprenons
l'évangile
de manière
expérimentale
on a pu
venir vers Dieu
attiré
par nos idolâtries
terrestres
temporelles
mais c'est impossible
pour un vrai chrétien
venir voir
dissiper
les lumières
de toutes les étoiles
lorsqu'il
l'amour
des dieux
révélé en Christ
se manifeste
envers les croyants
par un dieux
qui donne
son tout
son mieux
la chose
la plus aimable
de l'univers
la personne
qui a l'objet
de l'amour
des anges
des dieux
lui-même
pour mourir
pour moi
afin de me
réconcilier
avec Dieu
donc les biens
souverains
de chrétien
déviant
l'amour
des dieux
révélé en Christ
voilà pourquoi
on n'est pas là
pour dire
que le mieux
des dieux
est encore à venir
le mieux
des dieux
est déjà
venu
il est déjà
manifesté
c'est cet amour
la croix
et donc
agape
il ne parle plus
d'un côté
si on reste
qui est
avec la définition
étymologique
avec un amour
fraternel
plein d'affection
une bienveillance
bonne volonté
toujours avec
une connotation
des fêtes
d'amitié
et donc
il y a
toujours une affection
profonde
c'est pas
tout simplement
aimer
sacrificiellement
malgré
les fêtes
que je ne l'aime
pas même
car il y a
ce mix
de sentiments
car la personne
n'est pas
digne
de mon amour
et quelque part
Dieu lui-même
déteste
les péchés
et les pécheurs
qui est abominable
aux yeux
des dieux
mais Dieu
par sa détermination
surmontante
d'amour
va aimer
malgré sa condition
avec la détermination
d'un aimant
sincèrement
rendre cette personne
aimable
donc nous aimons
malgré
afin de rendre
la personne
aimable
et donc
c'est intéressant
car
les contextes
bibliques
il fait
que la compréhension
de l'amour
devienne
beaucoup plus riche
car les mots
agape
n'étaient pas
très utilisés
dans les littératures
grecques
de l'époque
mais la bible
a choisi
quelque part
les auteurs
et les traducteurs
ont choisi
surtout agape
pour décrire
et dans tous les contextes
bibliques
où agape
apparaît
il y a cette notion
d'un amour
qui s'édonne
déterminé
à se sacrifier
qui rénonce
mais c'est clair
que la bible
elle nous présente
non seulement
la compréhension
terminologique
d'amour
dans les contextes
de plusieurs passages
différents
mais la bible
elle décrit
l'amour aussi
de manière
objective
les problèmes
c'est que
dans les passages
où l'amour
est décrit
de la manière
la plus objective
on perçoit
clairement
que l'amour
reste
incompréhensible
il n'est pas
passible
d'une description
exhaustive
ce qui renforce
notre conviction
que l'amour
biblique
n'est pas citant
quelque chose
à être discuté
théoriquement
par les théologiens
ou d'être
tout simplement
pratiqué
de manière
aveugle
sans aucun sentiment
et l'amour
biblique
elle est beaucoup
plus quelque chose
qui doit être
expérimenté
ressenti
reçu
de la part
de Dieu
et qui doit être
reproduite
ou manifestée
c'est de recevoir
l'amour de Dieu
et déborder
de l'amour de Dieu
envers les autres
donc si on prend
par exemple
la complexité
la richesse
de l'amour
présenté
en premier
Corinthien 13
l'apôtre Paul
va dire
quand je parlerai
les langues
des hommes
et des anges
si je n'ai pas
la charité
ou l'amour
je suis un errant
qui résonne
ou un s'emballe
qui retient
qui retentit
pardon
et quand j'aurai
les dons des prophéties
la science
de tous les mystères
et toute la connaissance
quand j'aurai même
toute la foi
jusqu'à transporter
les montagnes
si je n'ai pas
de l'amour
je ne suis rien
donc c'est ce qu'il est
en train de dire
vous pouvez vivre
votre spiritualité
mettant toute l'emphase
sur les grandes oeuvres
religieuses
mais de manière
complètement fragmentée
en manquant d'amour
manifester les dons
des langues
des hommes
ou des anges
faire beaucoup
de bruit
dans une communauté
pour se dire
plus spirituel
que les autres
et être incapable
d'aimer
voici les dons
du Saint-Esprit
qui démontrent
que je suis rempli
du Saint-Esprit
c'est pas comme
la Bible présente
avoir les dons
c'est une chose
être rempli
c'est une autre chose
du Saint-Esprit
se montre plus
vers les fruits
de l'Esprit
et pas citant
par les dons
spectaculaires
après ces cultes
soi-disant des réveils
comment cet homme
traite sa femme
ses enfants
ou les serviteurs
les plus amples
au sein de la communauté
c'est par là
qu'on verra
s'il est ou non
rempli du Saint-Esprit
quand j'aurai
les dons des prophéties
il peut agir
comme un prophète
ou la science
de tous les mystères
et toute la connaissance
c'est à dire
il peut être
un grand théologien
et même peut-être
un soi-disant prophète
mais s'il n'y a pas
de l'amour
c'est rien
il peut être
celui
que Dieu peut utiliser
pour transporter
les montagnes
faire des miracles
ou faire
des larges dons
à la communauté
afin d'être vu
par les hommes
comme disait
le Christ
sans amour
ça ne vaut rien
je peux distribuer
tous mes biens
pour la nourriture
des pauvres
quand je livrerai
même mon corps
pour être brûlé
si je n'ai pas l'amour
ça ne sert à rien
et là il passe
à expliquer
ce qu'il y a
l'amour
par plusieurs
manifestations
l'amour est patient
plein de bonté
n'est point vieux
n'est s'éventer point
n'est s'enfle pas
d'orgueil
ne fait rien
des malhonnêtes
n'est cherche point
son propre intérêt
n'est s'irrite point
n'est soupçonne pas
les mal
n'est s'éventer point
de l'injustice
n'est s'éventer
réjoui de la vérité
elle excuse tout
croit tout
espère tout
supporte tout
la charité
n'est péris
jamais
donc c'est intéressant
de considérer
que nous ne sommes pas
devant une liste exhaustive
mais des manifestations
qui se manifestent
de manière constante
et symétrique
et équilibrée
devant des circonstances
différentes de la vie
et lorsqu'on est devant
une personne
qui aime
qui déborde
de l'amour de Dieu
c'est quelque part
cette constance
d'amour
et d'amabilité
qui ressort
nous n'arrivons pas
à décrire
la vie de cette personne
comme s'il allait
toujours
s'éporter
de la même manière
devant les mêmes circonstances
il nous manquerait
la capacité
de décrire
toutes les situations
possibles
envers lesquelles
il pourrait agir
différemment
mais la réalité
c'est que
lorsque nous sommes
devant quelqu'un
qui est haine
nous constatons
clairement
que cette personne
est aimable
et donc
d'un côté
il y a toute une complexité
pour considérer l'amour
mais de l'autre côté
c'est très simple
Jean
première lettre
des gens
en chapitre 4
nous pouvons lire
verset 7
bien aimer
aimons les uns
les autres
car l'amour
est des dieux
et quiconque
aime
est né des dieux
et connaît dieux
celui qui n'aime pas
n'a pas connu dieux
car dieux
est amour
donc l'amour
n'est pas dieux
mais dieux
!
dieux
est tellement
capital
à point
de décrire
son être
dieux
il est
l'être
le plus
aimable
dieux
est l'être
le plus capable
d'aimer
et dieux
subsiste
en amour
voici pourquoi
c'est logique
et c'est impossible
dieux
étant un être
relationnel
personnel
qu'il ne soit pas
plus réel
donc la doctrine
de la trinité
c'est une nécessité
car si dieux
est amour
et dieux
est éternel
dieux
a dû
interagir
dans des relations
d'amour
pendant toute
l'éternité
et dieux
subsiste
en amour
dans l'amour
plein
et pourquoi
car quelque part
soyez avec moi
il est raisonnable
que l'amour
soit une réponse
à l'amabilité
à la dignité
de l'objet
de l'amour
les passions
d'adolescence
parfois
n'ont aucun sens
car la personne
ne connait pas
à fond
cette illusion
qu'elle a créée
et elle va
supervaloriser
mettre en valeur
une idéalisation
des perfections
que l'autre n'a pas
et bientôt
cette idole
sera cassée
car on va connaître
vraiment
qui est la personne
nous sommes tous
pécheurs
imparfaits
et donc
cette passion
d'adolescence
va casser
par contre
Dieu
est le seul être
qui a la capacité
de supporter
de sponsoriser
l'amour
infini
voilà pourquoi
la Bible
elle n'hésite pas
à nous exhorter
à aimer Dieu
de tout notre cœur
de toute notre connaissance
de toutes nos forces
car ce sont
les manières
par lesquelles
on expérimente
l'amour
et
les manières
par lesquelles
on manifeste
l'amour
on connaît
des vertus
appréciables
chez une personne
et notre réponse
c'est admiration
amour
nos affections
sont légitimement
éveillées
réveillées
et maximisées
envers ces personnes
ou ces vertus
car ces vertus
elles vont au-delà
d'une appréciation théorique
mais
je tombe
amoureux
donc la connaissance
des vertus
des dieux
par exemple
sa sagesse infinie
sa bonté infinie
sa toute puissance
nous avons tous
des demandes
chez nous
de pouvoir
comprendre
combien digne
d'amour est Dieu
dans toutes ses facettes
et nos affections
se dirigent
vers Dieu
dans sa direction
ou dans toutes ses directions
voilà pourquoi
peu importe
qu'elle soit
l'étape
dans notre vie
où nous avons
expérimenté
l'amour
de Dieu
qui sera toujours
partiel
chaque progression
dans la connaissance
de Dieu
a la capacité
d'exiger
de nous
notre maximum
au niveau
d'adoration
intellectuelle
d'affection
et de manifester
cet amour
pour Dieu
par notre service
donc Dieu
il est
totalement aimable
dans toutes ses facettes
mais Dieu
est totalement aimable
lorsqu'il se présente
lorsqu'une personne
a une rencontre
avec Dieu
lorsque nous ne sommes pas
qui est en train
de raconter
et de rassembler
des informations
de l'amabilité
de Dieu
exposé
dans sa création
dans les choses
qui nous entourent
dans sa patience
dans sa grâce
mais lorsque par
l'esprit
de Dieu
communique à nos esprits
que nous sommes aimés
des dieux
et nous connaissons
l'amour des dieux
de manière expérimentale
notre capacité
d'aimer
l'évidence
d'avoir connu
l'amour des dieux
c'est cette expérience
qu'on a eue
avec Dieu
et donc nous grandissons
lorsque la Bible
nous dit
celui qui n'aime pas
n'a pas connu Dieu
car Dieu est amour
verset 16
et nous
nous avons connu
l'amour
que Dieu a pour nous
et nous y avons cru
donc la connaissance
de l'amour des dieux
qui produit la foi
qui sauve quelque part
Dieu est amour
et celui qui demeure
dans l'amour
demeure en Dieu
et Dieu demeure en lui
donc quelle est
la considération
pour nous
la plus importante
c'est que lorsque
nous connaissons
l'amour des dieux
un amour
expérimental
et s'il n'y a pas
cette expérience
d'amour avec Dieu
il faut chercher
par les saint-esprit
dans les saint-esprit
supplié au saint-esprit
qu'est notre connaissance
parfois théorique
de l'évangile
l'admiration
que l'on a
par rapport à l'amour
que ceux qui nous entourent
ont envers Dieu
qui s'affichent aussi
par leur capacité
d'aimer les autres
mieux que nous-mêmes
qui s'affichent aussi
par la manière
dont avec leur force
ils sont en train
de servir Dieu
plus que nous-mêmes
à la fin des comptes
il n'y a pas
des grands hommes
des dieux
des grandes femmes
il y en a ceux
qui ont plus
des convictions
d'être aimés
par Dieu
et qui ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher
de manifester
par leur service
et par leur amour
par leur rénoncement
quelle est la taille
de la largeur
hauteur
profondeur
de l'amour
des dieux
qu'ils ont expérimenté
et qu'ils sont en train
d'éteindre
envers les autres
car c'est l'amour
des dieux
produit par l'esprit
que nous manifestons
par les fruits
c'est un amour
dans lesquels
dieux nous a insérés
plutôt qu'un amour
qui nous pourrions
produire de nous-mêmes
nous sommes les branches
greffées
à la sec
au Christ
et c'est son amour
qui découle
de lui
à travers nous
envers les autres
donc les croyants
doivent s'approfondir
dans la définition
des termes
la description
biblique d'amour
qui peut être
si complexe
comme 1er Corinthien 13
ou si simple
comme la phrase
Dieu est amour
plutôt une question
pas d'une capacité
de décrire
mais une question
d'expérimenter
de connaître
d'identifier
chez nous
et manifester
de manière multiforme
envers les autres
les croyants
doivent aussi
s'approfondir
de manière
très intentionnelle
de cette connaissance
expérimentale
d'amour
dans toute l'atmosphère
des pages bibliques
c'est très important
pour nous
on a
cette hérésie
qui semble avoir
été
diffusée
et contaminée
la compréhension
des croyants
d'ailleurs
les églises
les plus légalistes
sont fondées
sur cette hérésie
l'hérésie
c'est l'idée
que l'Ancien Testament
présente
en Dieu
ou même
une attitude
des dieux
envers l'humanité
différente
du Dieu
du Nouveau Testament
et pour continuer
de rendre
les personnes
esclaves
des menaces
d'un Dieu
qui peut
n'importe quel moment
nous virer
et qui nous
pouvons perdre
les saluts
on va pendre
l'image des dieux
comme si c'était
un Dieu
contre nous
toujours très intéressé
à nous supprimer
de l'atmosphère
de la grâce
par contre
l'amour
des dieux
a toujours
été manifesté
dans toutes les pages
des écritures
donc en faisant
une lecture
panoramique
des écritures
en lisant
toutes les écritures
en étant assuré
de l'amour
des dieux
nous pouvons
expérimenter
dans toutes les pages
des écritures
l'amour
des dieux
envers nous
quand on fait
un panorama
en considérant
les principaux
événements
liés à notre
rédemption
on commence
avec la création
où Dieu
nous a créés
par amour
et pour aimer
il n'y a jamais
eu en Dieu
une nécessité
pour créer
l'univers
ou l'humanité
Dieu était
parfaitement
satisfait
par cette relation
intra-trinitaire
où les trois
personnes de la
trinité
étaient face à face
vis-à-vis
au commencement
la parole
était Dieu
vis-à-vis
face à face
face à Dieu
ok
elle était
Dieu
avec Dieu
donc la réalité
c'est que
depuis toujours
depuis toute l'éternité
avant la création
de l'univers
ou de l'être humain
Dieu
il débordait
des joies
dans la contemplation
mutuelle
des perfections
de chacune des
personnes de la trinité
en ayant une relation
d'amour mutuelle
où rien ne manquait
sauf que
l'amour
de Dieu
a la tendance
à déborder
à créer
par exemple
l'humanité
afin que
d'autres êtres
intelligents
personnels
aient la capacité
de réjouir
de la joie
d'une relation
d'amour
avec Dieu
Dieu a créé
tout l'univers
pour manifester
la sagesse
l'intelligence
la beauté
et la bonté
des dieux
pour nous entourer
des convictions
de combien
Dieu aime
et en contemplant
combien Dieu aime
combien Dieu est
aimable
en mettant
toutes les empreintes
de son amabilité
dans la création
en créant
l'être humain
avec les privilèges
suprêmes
d'être
vis-à-vis
des dieux
c'est-à-dire
image des dieux
face à Dieu
le sens
de l'existence
humaine
c'est
d'être
devant l'objet
l'objet
suprême
d'amour
d'amabilité
aimer Dieu
en recevant
cet amour
manifester
la vie
d'amour
de Dieu
et rendre
Dieu aimable
par la manière
dont on aime
les autres
et la création
c'est ça
les buts
de notre existence
prendre plaisir
en Dieu
et vivre
une vie
qui les glorifie
qui démontre
par acte
et parole
combien aimable
est notre Dieu
donc la création
même
à l'occasion
de la chute
nous voyons
de manière
très claire
que Dieu
a dilué
son jugement
et il a couvert
des grâces
et miséricordes
c'est Dieu
le premier
qui va porter
les vêtements
faits
des peaux
d'animaux
les premiers
les sacrifices
qui étaient déjà
en type du Christ
qui viendraient
c'est Dieu
le premier
qui avait dit
que la mort
serait inévitable
pour notre corruption
mais qu'au lieu
de nous lancer
directement
à l'enfer
va développer
par sa patience
un plan de rédemption
grâce envers
toute l'humanité
car pendant
que les plans
de rédemption
se développent
toute l'humanité
est préservée
et les jours
du jugement
viendra
mais Dieu
a développé
une manière
et il a ponté
déjà dès le départ
envers les descendants
qui viendraient
son fils
lui-même
qui serait
envoyé
donc depuis la chute
cette miséricorde
cette compassion
est manifestée
cet amour
des dieux gracieux
quand on va
vers les dix commandements
c'est aussi
un moment capital
dans l'histoire
de l'adoption
nous sommes devant
quelque part
un rappel
de ce qui signifie
être image des dieux
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
obéir
observer les dix commandements
c'est tout simplement
de vivre la vie d'amour
qu'on devrait vivre
qui d'entre
toute la race de l'humanité
peut s'élever
pour dire
qu'un seul
des commandements
n'est pas aimable
la première partie
des dix commandements
qui vise
à protéger
les seuls
objets suprêmes
d'amour
capables
de nous satisfaire
pour qu'on ne soit pas
perdu en tant
de chercher
dans les choses
créées par Dieu
de remplir en vide
c'est qu'est Dieu
qui peut remplir
donc les premiers commandements
qui cherchent
à préserver
Dieu
comme l'objet
suprême
exclusive
tu n'auras
aucun autre Dieu
devant ma face
il y a un seul vrai Dieu
c'est-à-dire
les mots Dieu
c'est
cet être suprême
bienheureux
le seul
qui a la capacité
de remplir
les démons
les plus profonds
de notre âme
Dieu nous a créés
pour lui
et l'âme humaine
n'a qu'il ne repos
lorsqu'elle se retourne
vers lui
donc lorsqu'il dit
tu n'auras pas
d'autres dieux
devant ma face
c'est déjà
car il n'existe pas
d'autres dieux
aucune imagination
humaine
ne peut inventer
un dieux
qui soit
si digne
d'être traité
en tant que dieux
comme les dieux
qui s'est révélé
soi-même
dans la Bible
les dieux
de la Bible
n'est pas tout simplement
infiniment supérieur
à toute autre
conception religieuse
des dieux
les dieux de la Bible
elle est seule
capable
de correspondre
à toutes les attentes
que la conception
des divinités
puisse exiger
et donc Dieu
lorsqu'il va exiger
adoration exclusive
envers lui-même
c'est un bien
qu'il est en train
de nous faire
pour qu'on ne cherche
pas à satisfaire
nos demandes
les plus profondes
celle d'être
en relation
avec Dieu
en nous rapportant
vers des personnes
ou des choses
ou des idoles
imaginées
comme s'ils avaient
la capacité
de nous donner
ce que Dieu seul
peut nous donner
et de satisfaire
nos âmes
le deuxième commandement
qui nous apprend
à comment maximiser
notre moment
d'intimité
avec Dieu
c'est un Dieu
qui a révélé
son amabilité
par toutes les choses
qui nous entourent
mais qui a toujours
mis en emphase
les privilèges
exclusifs
des êtres humains
d'être en relation
avec lui
de manière intime
et Dieu donc
a déterminé
de manière très détaillée
comment par exemple
un culte
des vrais
s'est déroulé
tu ne feras
point d'idole
le deuxième commandement
est préoccupé
à nous enseigner
comment adorer
les vrais
Dieu
voilà pourquoi
le nouveau testament
nous apporte aussi
des principes
quels sont
les éléments
du culte
pourquoi nous ne
perdons pas
du temps
en insérant
dans un culte
des éléments
qui vont
plutôt diverger
ou divertir
les personnes
distraire
de l'objet
de l'adoration
car Dieu
il a du plaisir
à maximiser
l'expérience
de son amour
par la pureté
et le respect
des principes
publics du culte
voilà pourquoi
on n'a pas un ministère
des danses ici
ou des théâtres
c'est la bible
elle-même
le nouveau testament
lui-même
qui nous dit
ce qu'il faut avoir
dans un culte
et c'est par là
que nous allons
maximiser
notre expérience
d'amour avec Dieu
Dieu a les plaisirs
le Saint-Esprit
qui a inspiré
les écritures
a du plaisir
à honorer
les respects
des écritures
par sa présence
et sa présence
nous apporte
la connaissance
expérimentale
de l'amour des dieux
le troisième commandement
qui nous enseigne
à garder
l'aspect sacré
de toute invocation
des dieux
et pas dire
les noms des dieux
envers
ou des choses sacrées
c'est pour nous protéger
de ne jamais
évoquer
ou invoquer
les noms des dieux
sans qu'on soit
en même temps
en train d'invoquer
Dieu lui-même
de ne jamais parler
des dieux
à la légère
s'il nous donne envie
de parler des dieux
tant mieux
qu'on s'arrête
et qu'on l'adore
c'est cette conscience
constante
d'adoration
dans notre relation
avec Dieu
le quatrième commandement
qui nous parle
de cet aspect sacré
de cette relation
hebdomadaire
avec Dieu
un jour sur sept
pour nous
les dimanches
en nous rappelant
que nous sommes
devant les fesses
de l'âme
c'est la célébration
tous les dimanches
nous allons nous rencontrer
avec notre bien-aimé
c'est pour protéger
la relation d'amour
entre Dieu
et les hommes
quand on va
vers les
six derniers commandements
nous sommes
c'est tellement beau
mais
nous sommes en train
d'en ayant
expérimenté
l'amour des dieux
envers nous
et notre amour
envers Dieu
nous débordons
de l'amour des dieux
dans toute la structure sociale
dans toutes les directions
de notre relation
aimer Dieu
sur toutes choses
et les prochains
comme nous-mêmes
et donc on a
les principes
d'honorer
et de respecter
la relation
entre parents
et enfants
car ça nous enseigne
que de la même manière
que Dieu exerce
son autorité envers nous
par un amour paternel
on doit être équilibré
dans ces deux sphères
ça nous parle aussi
de ne pas tuer
c'est véritablement
l'opposé suprême
de l'amour
car on a été créé
pour promouvoir
la vie à toute échelle
à toute échelle
et nous voyons
comment on est
dans une génération
abominable
car on est en train
de vouloir
supprimer la vie
depuis sa jeunesse
avortément
et là c'est promouvoir
la vie
n'est pas tuer
et plus intéressé
que nous sommes en train
de promouvoir
la vie
et respecter
les relations
d'alliance
l'adultère
ou les impuretés sexuelles
sont interdites
au septième commandement
car Dieu nous appelle
à honorer
et promouvoir
les modèles
suprêmes
qui Dieu a choisi
des créés
pour illustrer
la relation d'alliance
entre Christ
et l'Église
c'est une manière
dont les chrétiens
qui aiment Christ
affichent
par leur fidélité
dans les mariages
par les bons fonctionnements
des relations maritales
l'homme qui exerce
les rôles corrects
la femme qui exerce
par là
on est en train
d'afficher
combien nous chérissons
cette suture
d'amour
d'alliance
car nous dépendons
de cette suture
d'alliance
d'amour
pour rester connecté
à Christ
et il ne va jamais manquer
et bien sûr
que la bénéglité
la générosité
là on a
n'est pas dérobée
mais les principes
d'amour du Nouveau Testament
disent que c'est lui
qui dérobait
mettre notre travail
avec ses proprements
en faisant ses quêtes bien
pour avoir du quoi
aider
ceux qui sont dans les besoins
c'est l'amour
n'est pas mentir
car Dieu
a manifesté
son amour
envers nous
lorsqu'on ne le méritait pas
toujours
en respectant
la vérité
c'est l'amour du Christ
par exemple
devant la femme samaritaine
qui veut tellement
qu'elle embrasse Christ
comme son sauveur
mais qui ne va pas
négliger l'effet
qu'elle est en train
d'avoir une relation
à butère
et qu'elle doit
délaisser
cette relation
car
sans
répentance
véritable
sans vérité
sans transparence
dans cette relation
il n'y a pas de salut
donc tous les dix commandements
que les choses soient commises
au niveau pratique
au niveau du cœur
sont en train de protéger
et préserver
les relations d'amour
envers Dieu
et envers les autres
les résumés de la loi
que ce soit dans l'Ancien Testament
qui est dans les nouveaux
écoute Israël
l'Éternel
notre Dieu
l'Éternel est un
tu aimeras l'Éternel
ton Dieu
de tout ton cœur
toute ton âme
toute ta force
c'est ça qui résume
l'Ancien Testament
amour pour Dieu
quand on pense
aux lois
lévitiques
qui nous rappellent
les besoins du Christ
qui viendraient
comme sacrifice
pour nos péchés
il nous fait réfléchir aussi
qu'en même temps
que Dieu nous montre
quelle est la vie d'amour
qu'on devrait avoir
il pourvoit déjà
pour nos manquements
miséricorde
pardon
sacrifice
il nous rappelle
que la chose la plus importante
dans notre vie
n'est pas d'arriver
à la terre promise
mais de réjouir
de cette relation avec Dieu
dans les tabernacles
il nous rappelle
que l'accès
à la présence
de Dieu
est la richesse
la plus importante
et lorsqu'il est
suprême sacrificateur
est là pour illustrer
l'amour du Christ
il doit porter
dans sa poitrine
les noms
des douze tribus
pour que l'amour
soit toujours lié
à la représentation
de chaque croyant
qui s'est converti
l'amour du Christ
n'est pas un amour général
pour nous tous
l'amour du Christ
est un amour individuel
lorsqu'il marchait
vers la croix
il était en train
de souffrir
sur lui
des punitions
pour chacun d'entre nous
nous représenter
devant Dieu
et non seulement
pour souffrir
la punition
devant Dieu
mais pour
accéder
une fois
accompli
son oeuvre
d'expiation
au trône
de la grâce de Dieu
donc notre vie
aujourd'hui
est cachée
en Christ
nous sommes devant
les trônes glorieux
des dieux
en Jésus Christ
car Christ
nous a représentés
individuellement
il nous représente
et quand on pense
aussi aux lois civiles
les soins
envers les animaux
envers les étrangers
les soins
envers les pauvres
nous voyons partout
les principes
d'amour
il n'y a pas
de différence
entre les dieux
de l'Ancien Testament
les dieux
du Nouveau Testament
mais c'est clair
que la Bible
nous enseigne surtout
à contempler
et constater
l'amabilité
des dieux
dans les visages
du Christ
et ça c'est la chose
la plus importante
pour nous
les évangiles
les Nouveaux Testaments
nous montrent
de manière très claire
très évidente
qu'en Jésus Christ
Dieu
a manifesté
son amabilité
plus que jamais
si nous voyons
par exemple
la gloire
de toutes les choses
qui ont été créées
et la Bible nous dit
que c'est lui
qui a été incarné
c'est celui
qui soutient
toutes les choses
par sa parole puissante
c'est lui
par qui toutes les choses
ont été créées
qui appelle les étoiles
par les noms
la beauté glorieuse
du Christ
qui non seulement
est celui
par qui
Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
mais c'est lui
qui soutient
tout ce qui existe
aujourd'hui même
Dieu qui a fait
tout converger
en Jésus Christ
nous comprenons
que si nous avions
par la corruption humaine
la difficulté
de nous sentir aimés
par Dieu
ou d'identifier
la malignité des dieux
lorsqu'il est croyant
contemplant la vie
du Christ
dans les pages
des évangiles
il constate
son amabilité
quels sont les passages
!
qui vous touchent les plus
par rapport à l'amabilité
du Christ
cette symétrie
ou parfois
par amour
l'abîme dit
qu'en ayant fixé
son égard
envers celui
qui aimait l'argent
les jeunes riches
les chinois
!
qui l'avait besoin
de Christ
c'est les chinois
les chinois
en pleurant
par amour
ému de compassion
l'un des passages
pour ma préféré
c'est lorsque Christ
après avoir envoyé
les douze
et lui-même
après avoir travaillé
beaucoup
par les guérisons
par les prédications
un marxiste
il appelle les disciples
pour se reposer
sauf que lorsqu'ils essayent
de se reposer
ils rentrent dans une bâque
c'est légitime
de se reposer
mais lorsqu'ils essayent
de traverser
les lacs
les multitudes
en courant
cherchent
à suivre les Christ
et les Christ
émus
de compassion
d'amour
voient que
ces hommes
sont comme des
brébis
sans déroulé
et qu'ils continuent
d'enseigner
pendant toute la journée
jusqu'au soir
cet amour
qui ne les laisse pas
reposer parfois
devant l'opportunité
du service
cet amour
qui lui a fait
qu'après les voyages
envers sa Marie
au lieu de manger
les disciples
n'arrivaient pas
à comprendre
pourquoi
il est en train
de parler
avec cette femme
il se demandait
si quelqu'un
lui avait apporté
à manger
et Jésus
qui va dire
j'ai une nourriture
faire la volonté
de mon père
les Christ
donc
par la symétrie
de sa vie
parfois
en manifestant
positivement
l'amour
parfois
en parlant
de l'amour
de Dieu
se révèle
comme l'être
le plus aimable
surtout
par sa capacité
d'aimer
les plus
il aime
les plus aimables
il devient
nos yeux
donc
lorsque
nous
les chrétiens
nous voulons
connaître
l'amour
du Saint-Esprit
nous devons
nous rappeler
que l'objectif
du Saint-Esprit
c'est de pointer
l'amour
de Dieu
et l'amabilité
dans les visages
du Christ
les croyants
doivent
focaliser
sa connaissance
de l'amour
surtout
en Jésus-Christ
cette
amabilité
du Christ
est révélée
dans l'interaction
d'amour
entre les fils
et les pères
la manière
dont les Christs
nous parlent
de l'amabilité
de Dieu
ou qu'il révèle
combien Dieu
est mal
par la manière
dont il vit
une vie d'amour
mais aussi
la manière
dont les pères
ont déclaré
toute son affection
vers les fils
dans la montagne
de la transfiguration
voici mon fils
bien-aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute ma affection
à lui
écouter
la Bible
nous présente
les Christs
comme celui
qui Dieu
nous a sauvés
par lui
qui nous a transportés
des ténèbres
au royaume
de son fils
bien-aimé
notre problème
en tant qu'être
humain
c'est qu'on a
perdu les palais
pour Dieu
vous savez
j'ai dû apprendre
!
ici en France
à apprécier
certaines choses
qui étaient étranges
à mon palais
certains fromages
qui ne sont pas très bons
des choses comme ça
par exemple
on parle
d'apprendre
à apprécier
ou élever
notre goût
pour la musique
et le problème
de l'être humain
c'est qu'il a perdu
les palais
pour les choses
les plus aimables
pour Dieu
Dieu
est l'être
attention
le plus aimable
il est aussi
l'être
le plus capable
de nous dire
ce qui
mérite
être aimé
quel est l'objet
suprême
de l'amour de Dieu
si vous voulez
mesurer
combien Christ
est aimable
chercher à mesurer
par le fait
que c'est lui
qui est amour
Dieu lui-même
va aimer
le Christ
avec toute
son affection
qui pourrait
encore
nous manquer
en termes
d'objet
de contemplation
en termes
de satisfaction
devant sa présence
délice
perpétuellement
ou comme
dit
les chiens
de Salomon
le Christ
est totalement
aimable
il est totalement
dans ses parties
aimable
dans son ensemble
parce que nous
cherchons à apprécier
admirer la joie
la patience
la paix
il suffit
de contempler
en Christ
la manifestation
infinie
de ses vertus
mais aussi
dans son ensemble
la beauté
de sa sainteté
et donc
les croyants
doivent toujours
chercher
à expérimenter
un amour
pour Christ
par la contemplation
de l'amabilité
du Christ
mais les croyants
aussi doivent
surtout connaître
l'amour
du Christ
en cherchant
par l'esprit
à expérimenter
l'amour du Christ
pour lui
nous devons
connaître
lire les pages
d'écriture
avec un Christ
vivant devant nous
vivifiant devant nous
en manifestant
son amabilité
mais un chrétien
doit aussi chercher
à se permettre
de recevoir
l'amour du Christ
de s'arrêter
lorsqu'il Christ
manifeste
son amour
qu'il nous connaît
par nom
chacune des brébis
du Christ
connaît sa voix
celui qui est
intéressé
pour tous
ceux qui ont
travers
celui qui nous
enseigne
que tous
les cheveux
de notre tête
sont comptés
celui qui nous
a dit
que
personne ne
peut manifester
un amour
plus grand
que celui-ci
de donner
sa vie
pour ses amis
et de considérer
que Christ
à la croix
il était en train
de souffrir
par amour
à moi
comme les pères
m'a aimé
je vous ai aussi
aimé
demeurer dans
mon amour
ou par exemple
la manière
dont Christ
va nous dire
sachant
que son heure
était venue
de passer
de ces mondes
au père
et ayant aimé
les siens
qui étaient
avec lui
il les a aimés
jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'au bout
il a mis
les combles
à son amour
qu'est-ce qu'il est
Christ à faire
il s'est sang
d'une serviette
et il commence
à laver les pieds
des disciples
en service
d'un esclave
nous nettoyer
nous purifier
promouvoir
notre vie
et surtout à la croix
il manifeste
son amour
souprême
pour nous tous
ce qui fait que
John Stott
a dit
que lorsqu'un chrétien
cherche une définition
d'amour
il ne va pas
vers les dictionnaires
il va vers les calvaires
un Christ
à la croix
surtout
nous sommes devant
la manifestation
suprême
de la joie
qui a été habilité
car les pères
allaient plus
pris plaisir
dans son fils
lorsqu'une nouvelle
couche
d'amabilité
en Christ
a été rajoutée
et là
les langages
nous manquent
mais
Christ
il est devenu
davantage
aimable
en subissant
à l'obéissance
envers la croix
à la souffrance
quelque chose
qu'il n'avait jamais
expérimenté
il n'avait pas
besoin d'expérimenter
mais la joie
de père
envers le fils
augmente
lorsque nous
contemplons
son fils
qui était déjà
infiniment aimable
en rajoutant
une couche
d'amabilité
par sa prédisposition
à mourir
pour nous
si on pense
à la paix
qui était
la seule
manière
et sublime
de nous réconcilier
avec Dieu
c'est cette paix
dont on parle
quand on parle
d'amour
c'est la paix
absolue
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
car Dieu
a fait la réconciliation
entre nous
les pécheurs
avec Dieu
par la croix
quand on pense
à tous les autres
aspects
si on pense
à la miséricorde
à la patience
de Dieu
Dieu a fait
cumuler
sa colère
contre nous
et tous nos péchés
il les a fait
déverser
sur Christ
à la croix
et donc
les Christ
déviants
l'objet
suprêmement
aimable
mais surtout
non seulement
pour ses moments
à la croix
mais ce qu'il a
achevé
par la croix
en étant
introduit
au trône céleste
comme agneau
immolé
et glorifié
pour être
pour toute l'éternité
l'objet suprême
d'adoration
et d'amour
même des anges
ces êtres
qui ont
un palais
élevé
parfait
qui prennent
plaisir en Dieu
pour toute l'éternité
et qui prennent
surtout plaisir
en Dieu
en Christ
donc c'est à nous
de nous permettre
et chercher
par les saints esprits
à cultiver
la conviction
que Christ
m'aime
avec son amour
tout son amour
et que je suis aimé
en Christ
comme Dieu aime
les Christ lui-même
et c'est impossible
qu'une personne
qui a expérimenté
cet amour
ne manifeste pas
envers les autres
quand on parle
d'aimer
les prochains
comme nous-mêmes
certains disent
que le problème
est résolu
on ne prend pas
du plaisir
en nous
tous les jours
on sait
qu'on est
fautif
qu'on n'est pas
diligent
comme il faut
on se réproche
à chaque jour
on sait
qu'on n'est pas
digne
de tout cet amour
sacrificiel
que nous avons
envers nous-mêmes
mais tous les jours
on essaie
de promouvoir
notre vie
de nous améliorer
on ne dépend pas
de nos sentiments
envers nous-mêmes
pour continuer
de chercher
à faire les biens
pour nous-mêmes
et donc Christ dit
faites
pour les autres
pareil
c'est clair
que selon la logique
de l'évangile
je dois aimer
l'autre
comme à moi-même
mais je dois aimer
l'autre
à cause du Christ
donc lorsqu'il me manque
de motivation
par rapport
à la difficulté
d'aimer quelqu'un
qui n'est pas très aimable
je dois l'aimer
à cause de mon amour
pour Christ
et je dois l'aimer
par devoir
car j'ai reçu
un traitement
du Christ
que je ne méritais pas
et donc je dois
à tous cet amour
mais jusque là
on n'est pas encore
en train de vivre
dans la dynamique
de l'amour du Saint-Esprit
on est dans une logique
où il y a encore
une absence
d'un amour expérimental
et la réalité biblique
c'est que
je dois aimer
non seulement
à cause
de la dignité
de tout être humain
qui a le potentiel
pour être restauré
en tant qu'image
de Dieu
et par l'exercice
d'amour
en m'efforçant
à aimer
en pratiquant
l'amour
je maximise
ma possibilité
de passer
à aimer
par des sentiments
aussi des personnes
donc c'est légitime
de les faire
il faut les faire
mais la pratique
véritable
qui peut nous faire
aimer véritablement
les autres
c'est d'être
une extension
de l'amour de Dieu
voilà pourquoi
et là je voulais
conclure en lisant
Ephésiens chapitre 3
à partir de verset 14
pour aimer comme il faut
comme Christ nous a aimé
lorsqu'on voit une personne
qui aime
qui aime comme Christ
par des renoncements
par des sacrifices
malgré
les manquements
chez les personnes
de provoquer
l'amour en nous
lorsque Dieu
nous a aimé
Ephésiens chapitre 2
nous a déjà dit
mais
lorsque Dieu
nous a aimé
il n'était pas
en train de chercher
en dehors
de lui-même
des raisons
pour nous aimer
en dehors
de lui-même
nous étions
une race
perdue
ennemie de Dieu
fils de colère
donc Dieu
il a cherché
au-dedans
de lui-même
une source
inépuisable
des capacités
d'aimer
les richesses
de sa grâce
et nous les chrétiens
pour reproduire
cet amour
on doit chercher
profondément
un Dieu
la perception
de son amour
afin que cet amour
déborde
à travers nous
envers les autres
aimer c'est
tout simplement
de vivre
comme une plateforme
pour la promotion
des vies des autres
rendez-vous
par la charité
esclave
les uns des autres
et voici
la description
totalement
organique
à partir
du verset 14
à cause
de cela
j'ai fléchi
les genoux
devant les pères
duquel tire
son nom
toute la famille
dans les cieux
et sur la terre
afin qu'il vous donne
selon la richesse
de sa gloire
d'être puissamment
fortifié
par son esprit
dans l'homme antérieur
donc le Saint-Esprit
qui va nous
fortifier
puissamment
dans l'homme antérieur
en sorte
que Christ
habite dans vos cœurs
par la foi
quand on parle
du fruit de l'esprit
on est en train
de parler
de la mesure
dont les Christ
habitent
dans mon cœur
afin
attention à ces deux termes
qui étant
enraciné
et fondé
dans l'amour
vous regardez
les bâtiments
les architectes
de l'église
peuvent vous aider
les plus élevés
sont en bâtiment
les plus évidents
à sa grandeur
les plus la fondation
a dû creuser
plus profondément
étant enraciné
pour les arbres
c'est la même chose
les plus fructifères
les plus résistantes
avant qu'on voit
visiblement
les fruits
à l'extérieur
il faut que ces racines
soient poussées
profondément
à nous
de nous approfondir
dans l'esprit
par la parole
de Dieu
avec nos yeux fixés
sur l'amour
de Dieu
révélé en Christ
au Saint-Esprit
de produire
et de manifester
et de faire
déborder en nous
cet amour
la loi du Christ
n'est pas fondée
sur des tâches
des cases accrochées
c'est fondé
sur une relation
expérimentale
d'amour
pour Christ
et en étant
fondé
et enraciné
dans l'amour
vous pourriez
comprendre
avec tous les sens
quelle est la largeur
la longueur
la profondeur
et la hauteur
et connaître
l'amour
de Christ
qui surpasse
toute connaissance
en sorte
qu'il vous soit
rempli
jusqu'à toute
la plénitude
des dieux
or à celui
qui peut faire
par la puissance
qui agit en nous
infiniment
au délard
de tout ce que nous
demandons
pensons
complètement hors contexte
et prendre ce texte
et parler
de prospérité terrestre
il peut faire
beaucoup plus
que nous imaginons
donc je vais déclarer
que j'aurai ma maison
dans un an
ici
il est en train
de parler
de notre capacité
d'aimer
de manifester
les fruits de l'esprit
à lui soit la gloire
dans l'église
et en Jésus Christ
dans toutes les générations
au siècle
des siècles
Amen